the nose swabs journey seems pretty
direct going from here to here to here
but before it ends here its journey may
continue as part of a mapping of genomic
sequences it's being used by scientists
all around the world to track the
emergence of sars cov2 variants here's
how it works
remember that no swap you took if it was
a pcr test around five to ten percent of
them end up here in laboratories set up
to conduct genomic sequencing genomic
sequencing is a process used to analyze
the genetic makeup of viruses sort of
like creating and then assembling really
large puzzles the sarsko v2 genome is
about 30 000 bases long it's an rna
single stranded positive rna virus and
that length if you just typed out the
a's u's and g's and c's is about the
same length as the us constitution and
bill of rights all viruses like cyrus
cov2 continually evolve as they
replicate those changes in the genetic
code are called mutations a variant has
one or more of these mutations labs
continuously analyze the genome of cyrus
kov2 to keep track of variants that pose
threats to public health a lot of the
laboratory testing itself is you know
moving a lot of tubes around the example
of contagion gives you a good sense of
what that process kind of looks like on
the back end blue is virus and the gold
is human and the red is the viral
attachment protein we have tools like
neck strain and microreact and others
that allow us to put sequence data into
place and time for stars cov2 most labs
use an approach called amplicon
sequencing which means that small
overlapping pieces of the genome are
amplified by pcr same sort of approach
that is used for testing they are
sequenced and then powerful
bioinformatic pipeline and algorithms
are used to then put those pieces back
together and compare them to other
genomes the sequencing is done by a mix
of academic and clinical laboratories
along with local state and federal
agencies
within two weeks from this sensation the
sequence is available in public
databases while lab results will tell
you if you're positive or negative they
most likely won't tell you what variant
you had but is there any way to find out
i think you can probably make an
educated guess if you were infected over
the summer and fall in the united states
the high likelihood just based on the
viruses that were circulating is that
you have a delta virus genetic
sequencing often focuses on the spike
protein since it's the tool the virus
uses to penetrate cells and spread
infection genomic sequencing monitors
mutations and allow scientists to assess
how evolving variants might impact
existing treatments if a variant emerges
it's classified by the cdc into four
categories variant being monitored
variant of interest variant of concern
and variant of high consequence let's
take a look at omicron which falls into
the variant of concern category omicron
does look pretty different from both
delta as well as many of the viruses
that went before it was first identified
by public health research groups in
botswana and south africa specifically
dr moyo and the team at the botswana
harvard aids institute partnership it
has an accumulation of 32 documented
mutations in the spike protein which
sounds like a lot because it is it has
that deletion at residue 69 and 70 which
lead to that sgtf or sg and target
failure marker that is often used to
understand where and how it's
transmitted that was important with some
of the early cases of omicron mostly
because a lot of what we've been seeing
in the united states over the course of
the summer and early fall was delta
which lacked that mutation so when you
started to see an increasing number of
these sgtf failures gave you a good
indication of how much omicron you're
seeing across your sample even when you
didn't have the sequencing data in hand
with variance of concern the existing
therapeutics vaccines and treatments all
still work to stop the viruses spread
but it may not be as effective the next
category variance of high consequence is
the most serious now we haven't seen a
variant of high consequence yet
homocrine is much more transmissible
than other reported variants it shows
evidence of immune invasion even among
vaccinated individuals and it's hitting
many communities and healthcare systems
hard the specific risk categorization
shouldn't mean that we treat any of
these viruses with any less seriousness
the emergence of new variants also begs
the question what should we call them
well the answer depends on who you ask
the pango nomenclature system looks like
b117 there are next strain nomenclatures
that are more like a named hurricane
type approach so those would be like a
21a or 21b they have usually a year and
then a letter all of these can be a
mouthful and so the who over the course
of last spring and summer brought
together a group to help name and
designate come up with a consistent
nomenclature system for variants of
interest and variants of concern the
names have to be specific they have to
be distinctive they have to be easy to
pronounce and search for in multiple
languages and most importantly they
shouldn't be associated with a specific
place or people if you think of viruses
like marburg
germany norwalk from ohio all of those
are viruses that are associated with the
places where they were first identified
sometimes pretty negatively so the who
decided on greek letters
it's hard to imagine the course of this
pandemic without genomic sequencing even
if you've never heard of it before it's
played an important role in monitoring
and adapting to the pandemics global
scale i think one of the most important
lessons at least from the point of view
of genomic surveillance is that open
data and rapid data sharing is an
incredibly useful tool for public health
and pandemic response the potential for
global public health is really exciting
but
there are a lot of barriers that we have
to overcome how do we pull all these
different types of data together how do
we actually collect the samples that we
need to collect in a timely way so that
we can get the information that we need
when you go to a test site and get your
nose swab you're really helping to
understand transmission dynamics so
that'll help us understand not only the
virus that infected you personally but
also
trends in your local region in your
state and across the country